في دراسه ان عملت في جامعه كامبردج
العريقه حاطه الاطباء النفسيين تحت المجهر
وفي قفص الاتهام الدراسه مع ان من سنه
2018 لكن مثلها مثل كثير اشياء هذه الايام
على السوشيال ميديا فجاه رجعت تم تداولها
وفاتحه نقاش كبيره الدراسه ايش بتقول
بتقول انه الدكاتره النفسيين عندهم
ازدواجيه في المعايير في اختيار العلاج
الامثل لما بيكونوا بيفكروا فيه مرضاهم
مقارنه بلما يكون الامر متعلق فيهم هم
نفسهم كيف يعني هذول الباحثين اللي شملوهم
بالدراسه كانوا همم او اخذوا بعين او
اخذوا عينه 515 طبيب نفسي انه الطبيب
النفسي في معظم الحالات لو بيفكر في علاج
لنفس شو بيختار دائما العلاج الاخف فمثلا
في الامراض مثل الاكتئاب الاطباء النفسيين
ما بيكتبوا لنفسهم دواء وبيفضل العلاج
بالمراقبه الحديثه ولو الموضوع متعلق
بامراض مثل الفصام او غيره فبيفضلوا وعلى
انه يتم حجزهم او فرق قيود معينه عليهم
يعني الواحد عاد الواحد طبعا يعني عاده
لما يحتار في العلاج مع اي طبيب بيقول لي
الدكتور يا دكتور لو انت مكاني ايش بتسوي
لكن يبدو بحسب هذه الدراسه انه الاطباء
النفسيين لما الانسان لهذا السؤال ما
بيقول الجواب الصحيح الحق اما الاسباب
فمجهوله بس من الناس عن من الصاج جلسه
طبعا بتحلل وبتاخذ وبتدي فاحنا قلنا خلينا
نفترض حسن النيه ونسمع منهم بنفسهم فاهمني
من عمان الطبيب النفسي محمد زهران اهلا
فيك معنا همم
خليني اول شيء ابتدي اسالك عن رايك الشخصي
في هذه الدراسه
يعني شوفي انا عشان يعني كبدايه بدي احكي
لك دليل العلمي طبيه لا يعتمد على دراسه
واحده اضعف دليل علمي اضعف دليل علمي هو
الدليل وراء الشخص اللي تروح على دكتور
يقول لك والله انا حسبته هذا اضعف دليل
علمي لكن اقوى دليل علمي اسمه ميته انا
لست اللي هو مجموعه عديده من الدراسات
التي
تمت بحيث انها تعتمد نتيجه معينه لا شيء
بحيث انه يطلع كلكم منديشن بالنهايه نقدر
احنا كاطباء ناخده ونحكي للاخرين للناس
يعني
2018 حقيقه ان انتشرت في في مجال علميه
ولكن دراسه من ال 2010 كانت معموله يعني
قديمه هي دراسه واحده وتم طرح السؤال فعلا
على عدد من الاطباء لكن هذا لا
يثبت بانه بان هذا يعني هاي النتيجه 100%
لو انت طرحت على الاطباء هاي هاي الاسئله
نفسها في الوقت الحالي ممكن يجاوبه ليش
ليش اه ليش انت بتقول لي يعني انه انت
رافض لهذا التعميم اللي جايب فيه هذه
الدراسه وانه العين يعني صغيره
في نقد في بعض
الدراسه طيب
اصلا انت لا يجوز ان تعالج نفسك انت طبيب
نفسي لا يجوز ان تعالج نفسي
اذا اي طبيب نفسي
كيف انتم تسالوا الاطباء نفسيين انه انت
لو مرضت» الموجوده
[موسيقى]
عند الناس تنطبق على نسبه الامر نسبه
الامراض موجوده عند العقبه نفسيه وعند
الاطباء العامين عند اي طبيب فهو بشري زيه
زي الناس
لو بتطرح عليهم الخيار فبيختاروا خيارات
غير اللي بيعطوها للناس وخليني اقول لك
حاجه ليش الان كمان هذه الدراسه لاقيه صده
كبير عند الناس يعني لانه كمان الان صار
في اتهامات للاطباء النفسيين بالافراط في
توزيع
الحبوب او الادويه اللي هي مضاده للاكتئاب
الى ذلك لكل احد يروح لهم كل ما احد يروح
لهم مجلس عندهم شويه يصرفه له دواء ضد
الاكتئاب كيف بترد على هذا الموضوع
دعاء يعني حقيقه احنا بنعتمد على الدليل
العلمي هلا سابقا يمكن ما كان في
الجايد لاين اوريكم انديشن
[موسيقى]
القايد لاين بحكي انه احنا لازم نعطي ابر
لمرضى الذهون اللي انكسر لكن بعد ال 210
صار في توصيات انه تقرير الانتكاسات في
دليل علمي قوي طلع ميته انا لسه زي ما
حكيت في البدايه
انه الانتكاسات تعالج في الابر فهما طرحوا
السؤال هذا على الاطباء اللي هم جاوبوا
انه انا ما بفضل الابر على نفسي بس ما كان
هذا الدليل العلمي اصلا طالع في وقت
بالنسبه لموضوع السؤال الاخر انهم السؤال
الثاني كان علي اكتئاب انه لو انت همم
يعني اجاك مريض هل انت بتنصح انه ياخذ
مضاد اكتئاب ولا انه يستنى هلا هذا السؤال
على المرضى امي بشكل عام جاوبوا انه انه
يلعطها مضاد الاكتئاب لكن هذا الشيء في
الوقت الحالي همم ليس يعني احنا ما بنلتزم
بالقايد فحسب درجه الاكتئاب بنحكي يعني في
في رجله خفيفه من الاكتئاب ممكن ان تعالج
بالثرب والعلاج الكلامي بالعلاج المعرفي
السلوكي
برده بحكي ميته انا لسه ال ال المتوسط
ممكن ان يعالج بالايذر يعني يا اما ثوره
يعني في اتجاه عالمي لصرف الادويه
وكلاهما معا افضل شيء يعني انه كلاهما
افضل شيء لكن كل ما اشد حدث الاكتئاب كل
ما كانت الدواء له يعني له فعاليه اكبر
فعاليه
فهذا الدليل العلمي هذا كله الحديث
الدراسي
محمد زهران شكرا لك
[موسيقى]